- [Narrator] I think the
average person imagines
a pirate with hook for a
hand, a great big, floppy hat,
blue waistcoats, and maybe even a peg leg,
parrot on his shoulder.
(parrot squawks)
- Yargh.
(upbeat sea shanty music)
- [Narrator] This particular
gang of pirates were active
in the very early part of the 18th century
for only four or five years,
but they included Blackbeard,
Black Sam Bellamy,
Stede Bonnet, the women pirates
Mary Read and Anne Bonny,
were all part of this one
gang, and it's this gang
that all of the pop culture
images and iconography
relating to pirates comes from.
One of the most common
oceanic sailing routes
for English seamen was to go
from England to the Caribbean
because that was a major
route of merchant shipping,
and so they would come back
to gray, dreary England
and one of the things they
would bring with them often
were these colorful
birds from the tropics,
especially parrots who
could be trained to sit
on your shoulder but also
to actually speak words.
You can imagine how
boring it must have been
on your off hours, what
are you going to do?
The colorful and talkative
parrots were treasured
both as a form of
entertainment and recreation,
all of the characteristics pirates had,
because, you know,
having a parrot as a pet,
missing arms, eyes, and hands and so forth
was very common amongst
sailors in that time period.
Most pirates had been
merchant or naval sailors
prior to going into piracy,
and the big piracy outbreak
was prompted by the ending
of a big colonial war, the
War of Spanish Succession.
You had thousands of people without means
to sustain themselves and
with a special skill set.
The pressures on sailors were enormous,
so many of them mutinied
and took over their vessels.
These pirates from the
Golden Age of Piracy
were folk heroes at the
time they were still alive.
They argued they weren't
thieves and brigands.
They said that they were engaged
in essentially a social revolt
against the ship captains and ship owners
who'd made ordinary
sailors' lives miserable,
that they were Robin
Hood figures, you know,
robbing from the wicked
rich to settle scores.
Many of them had been in accidents
because being a sailor,
whether a pirate or not,
aboard a ship was a very
dangerous proposition.
Rigging fell in storms, cargo
in barrels shifted around.
In battle you would be
hit by wood splinters
or who knows what else,
so lots and lots of pirates
and sailors also may have had
eye patches and peg legs and
hooks or other things for arms
because they'd lost their
eyes or limbs (laughs)
in these various accidents or in combat.
So the pirates probably
looked a little bit like
some crazy scene from, you
know, the early Mad Max movies,
a bunch of people bizarrely dressed
like a post-apocalyptic image,
and you know that was precisely the idea,
especially Blackbeard's, was
to cultivate a image of terror
so that everyone would
be so scared of them
they'd surrender without a fight,
but, in all the accounts of all
of Blackbeard's raids
and captures of ships,
he threatens a lot of people,
but he never actually kills anybody
prior to his final, fatal
battle with the Royal Navy.